.
CNN'S MATT RIVERS LOOKS AT THE
VIOLENCE.
>> AMARA AND BORIS, TODAY'S
MIDTERM ELECTIONS HERE IN MEXICO
ARE THE LARGEST TO TAKE PLACE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
MORE THAN 20,000 CANDIDATES FOR
A VARIETY OF OFFICES ON BALLOTS
NATIONWIDE, BUT THE PERSON WHO'S
BEING TALKED ABOUT WITH THE MOST
TO PERHAPS GAIN OR LOSE FROM THE
OUTCOME OF THESE ELECTIONS IS
SOMEONE WHO'S NOT EVEN ON VOTERS
BALLOTS, MEXICO'S PRESIDENT.
>> HERE IS ABEL MURIETTA, A
CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE.
CRIME WAS HIS NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
BUT JUST ONE DAY AFTER FILMING
THIS AD, HE WAS DEAD.
SHOT AND KILLED MAY 13th IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT ON A BUSY STREET
WHILE HANDING OUT CAMPAIGN
FLYERS.
STATE AUTHORITIES SAY MURIETTA
WAS DELIBERATELY TARGETED BUT
DON'T KNOW BY WHOM.
SUSPECTS OR NOT, THOUGH, IT'S
JUST FURTHER PROOF THAT IN
MEXICO, POLITICS CAN BE DEADLY.
FROM SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR
THROUGH MAY 25th, AT LEAST 88
POLITICIANS OR CANDIDATES HAVE
BEEN KILLED, ACCORDING TO
MEXICAN CONSULTING FIRM.
THEY'RE A PART OF THE MORE THAN
565 POLITICIANS OR CANDIDATES
OVERALL THAT HAVE BEEN TARGETED
BY SOME SORT OF CRIME RANGING
FROM MURDER TO ASSAULT TO
THREATS, THE FIRM SAYS.
GOVERNMENT SAYS IT BELIEVES BOTH
NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY FAR LOWER
THOUGH THEY DON'T SAY HOW THEY
TALLIED THEIR NUMBERS.
STILL, IT ADMITS THERE'S A
PROBLEM.
IT'S A DIFFICULT TIME FOR THESE
CAMPAIGNS SAYS MEXICO'S
PRESIDENT.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP PROTECTING
THEM.
THOUGH MEXICO HAS CONSISTENTLY
FAILED TO PROTECT ITS
CANDIDATES, POLITICAL
ASSASSINATIONS HAVE BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR DECADES BUT THIS
YEAR IS PARTICULARLY BAD.
>> I DO THINK THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
VIOLENT ELECTIONS IN MEXICAN
HISTORY.
>> Reporter: SECURITY EXPERTS
LIKE ANA MARIA SAYS CRIMINAL
GROUPS WANT THEIR PREFERRED
CANDIDATE IN OFFICE SO THEY
MIGHT TARGET OTHERS THEY DONE
LIKE, ESPECIALLY CANDIDATES WHO
MAKE CRIME A CENTER PIECE OF
THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
>> CANDIDATES THAT TALK THE WAY
ABEL MURRIETA SPEAK CLEARLY ARE
GOING TO RUN BIGGER RISKS.
>> MURRIETA WAS KNOWN FOR
CHALLENGING CRIMINAL GROUPS AND
DRUG CARTELS.
AS A PRIVATE LAWYER HE WAS ALSO
REPRESENTING AN OUTSPOKEN FAMILY
WITH DUEL U.S./MEXICO
CITIZENSHIP THAT LOST NINE OF
ITS MEMBERS WHEN THEY WERE
MURDERED BY SUSPECTED CARTEL
MEMBERS IN MEXICO IN LATE 2019.
TWEETING SHORTLY AFTER MURRIETA
WAS KILLED SAYING IN PART,
QUOTE, THEY HAVE KILLED MY
DEFENDER, WHAT DO WE CALL THIS,
THE RULE OF LAW.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE WAS KILLED
BECAUSE OF HIS OPPOSITION TO THE
CARTELS?
>> YES, HE WAS ALWAYS EXPOSING
THEM.
TO ME, HE DIED A MARTYR.
>> Reporter: AUTHORITIES HAVE
NOT IDENTIFIED ANY SUSPECTS OR
MOTIVE IN MURRIETA'S MURDER, BUT
THE VICTIM SEEMED TO KNOW HE WAS
AT RISK, SAYING THIS A FEW DAYS
BEFORE HE DIED.
HE WENT ON TO SAY THE STREETS
BELONG TO THE PEOPLE, NOT THE
CRIMINALS, AND SOME OF THOSE
PEOPLE TURNED UP HERE TO HIS
FUNERAL.
THEY GAVE HIM A STANDING OVATION
AS HI COFFIN WAS LED OUT.
NOW, I HAVE SPOKEN TO A NUMBER
OF FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS WHO DO
BELIEVE THE U.S. WILL ADDRESS
CONCERNS PUBLICLY SOMETIME SOON.
THE QUESTION IS IF THE POLITICAL
PARTY DOES WELL IN TODAY'S
ELECTIONS, WILL HE BE LESS
WILLING TO LISTEN TO WHAT THE
U.S. HAS TO SAY.
BEFORE I SEND IT BACK TO YOU
GUY, I SHOULD NOTE, LEVELS OF
VIOLENCE ARE THE HIGHEST THEY
HAVE BEEN.
ACCORDING TO MEXICAN CONSULTING
FIRM, AT LEAST 91 POLITICIANS
AND/OR CANDIDATES HAVE BEE